françois poulet mathis merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on le
disait à l'instant emmanuel macron va
recevoir les dirigeants espagnols et
suédois il échangera il échangera de
nouveau avec angela merkel
et puis avec lui était compté est ce que
finalement tout se joue maintenant avant
ce sommet et vous savez dans toute
négociation les positions générales ce
cas un durcissement près de la solution
pensez bien ce qui se passe si on peut
l'admettre qu'elle affirme et ses
gypsies qu'elle avait des doutes sur la
possibilité d'un accord en trois ans
c'est aussi parce fondamentalement elle
souhaite pousser les gens jusqu'à leurs
limites et les inciter de tête c'est
d'accepter des concessions trouver un
accord mais de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit quand même d'un budget
européen pluri-annuel site important de
milliards d'euros c'est quelque chose de
considérable et en plus ce qui est le
résultat d'un accord avec entre angela
merkel emmanuel macron 750 milliards
d'euros qui vont être injectés dans
l'économie européenne pour la relancer
le prêt c'est que ces 750 milliards
d'europe qui vont être d'euros qui vont
être mutualisés chute en fait la
commission européenne qui va acheter de
la dette sur les marchés
et bien cette dette va être mutualisés
or elle va profiter essentiellement aux
pays qui ont le plus souffert du contrat
virus est valide et ennemis l'espagne et
bien sûr la france
or d'autres pays ce qu'on appelle
précisément les pays qui sont près de
chez eux s'ils n'ont pas envie de voir
le budget chez prixtel que les quatre
pays en question
le danemark la suède les pays bas et
l'autriche
et bien c'est 4 2 ils disent qu il faut
des garanties avant de traiter la alors
clairement justement justement françois
poulet mathis selon vous qu'est ce qui
pourrait faire changer d'avis
les pays dits frugaux que vous venez de
citer alors les pays ce que don peuvent
changer dans la vie d'avis dans la
mesure où ils ont l'impression que
l'octroi de prêts et surtout de
subventions puisque les subventions
finalement c'est là on donne c'est de
l'argent qui n'est pas soumis un
remboursement à composition que ce
condition qu'ils aient un contre la
véritable contrôle de l'ensemble des 27
pays de l'union sur l'utilisation de ces
fonds et surtout un engagement de ces
pays à accompagner
finalement c'est suivant de réformes
profondes réformes de la rue konami
donc ils veulent ces gars entier il ya
eu beaucoup de pourparlers céda même
temps il va y en avoir encore demain et
peut-être dans la soirée ces pourparlers
ont pour objet finalement de faire
accepter à sept pays l'ine qui serait
quand même un tissu révolutionnaire en
europe
la difficulté est le drame du canda
virus qui a touché pas l'europe de
manière égale et bien que ce qu anna
virus puisse atteindre âme sur lequel
l'ensemble des pays d'europe et un
cuistre en revanche en injectant dans
l'école j ai enlevés tués lit jean leray
et s'affrontent c'est un je suis tanné
de frein au général
et c'est un renouveau sur de l'europe si
si effectivement un accord est trouvé ce
qui n'est pas encore le cas
alors justement est ce que c'est le plan
de la dernière chance pour laurent ou
alors est-ce qu'on se dirige vers le une
europe divisée entre les pays du nord et
les pays du sud
c'est un grand risque c'est un grand
risque mais tout le monde mesure le
risque quand l'allemagne d'angela merkel
à rien et j'ai que finalement elle était
obligée d'accepter l'idée de
mutualisation des efforts je pense
qu'elle a très bien compris
une menace qui concerne la thur même du
marché intérieur
toute l'économie européenne une telle
menace sera redoutable
y compris pour tous les pays pris
séparément et donc même les petits pays
qui actuellement est à peut-être
et ce n'est pas impossible que
finalement ils en viennent à une
certaine forme de raisons tu on peut on
leur donne des gages et ses gages c'est
quoi c'est la possibilité effectivement
d'avoir leur mot à dire
sur la manière dont l'argent qu'ils les
énormités de l'argent et c'est quand
même des 5,6 g
l'utilisation de cet argent ceux soumis
à un contrôle rigoureux la l'ensemble
fait par le biais de l'acquisition paix
départ le plus du concert église
merci beaucoup françois poulet mathis
devoir partager votre expertise sion de
rente elle rappelle que vous êtes
journalistes et spécialistes europe et